omar doesn't regret comparing american
israel to terrorist groups like the
taliban
and instead of apologizing for her
history of anti-semitic comments
omar launched a new attack on jewish
members of congress who have condemned
her
do you regret these comments i don't
i have welcomed any time you know my
colleagues have asked to have a
conversation
to to learn from them for them to learn
from me
i think it's really important for these
members to realize that they haven't
been
partners in injustice they haven't been
um you know equally engaging
in seeking justice uh around the world
and omar isn't getting any support from
the white house
any attempt to draw an equivalency
between the united states and our close
ally israel with a terror group like
hamas
or the taliban is false and unacceptable
representative omar has said that was
not her intent of her
comments but those certainly are not
comments that we've made from here
harold so does she help the white house
because in a way
by being so radical it that white house
looks more moderate by comparison when
she says these things
clearly she does not not help the white
house she doesn't help
democrats and i would argue if you try
to look at her words
in the most favorable light that she's
indeed looking to bring about
a solution to challenges in the middle
east she doesn't help that cause
either i think in fact she she
pushes back the opportunity or chances
of finding any kind of common ground
in fact i don't quite understand what
she's saying i mean the first thing
it sounded as if she her words on paper
sound as if she was drawing an
equivalency between us
the united states and terror
organizations as well as our most
important ally and reliable ally in the
region
she then suggested it maybe not and then
it sounds as if she's saying that is
that is not the case
she's making herself a candidate for
some sort of action in the congress if
these are the kinds of things that she
believes meaning
a removal from the committee i think has
to be thought about if indeed she shares
these views i heard
the words or saw the words and i saw
what i believe was a recanting in her
part
now i'm simply confused yeah um it
sounds like they're going to need a
peacemaker caucus within the democratic
democratic side here sooner rather than
later if we can't get to some uh
some some bottom of this it's pretty
interesting uh dana i don't know her
total history
but that she did she did flee a country
in somalia and then she comes to the
freest country on earth
but her criticism is always kind of like
born of like america being oppressive
so she fled a truly oppressive
experience and comes here
but sees us as somehow more impressive
than anything out there
and i think that's one of the reasons
why what harold's saying i think is very
true is that she's completely
unpersuasive
yeah to for people that would actually
with to listen to
her if she had points that she could
make that were persuasive
about what she's trying to achieve which
i understand would be right a homeland
for
palestine palestinians yeah that's what
she's looking for that's not what she
says
yeah so basically it's almost like for
example um gwen berry right on on
um at the podium when she's getting the
medal or what she got third
third um so that's totally unpersuasive
like you're not
able to like stand up and say i love
this country and because i love this
country i would really love for us to
stand up for justice and i think that
these people deserve better justice
and i want to work for that if she was
saying that then the white house
wouldn't have to say repeatedly like
every two weeks
we actually don't agree with that and
that's not something we would say and i
i don't think that she deserves a pass
any longer
this has been happened it's happened
over and over again
katie you know the re it must be
challenging for the media who are
bending over backwards not to criticize
her
because you know they wanted to just
shut up maybe you could become president
and your brother can be first dude who
knows
well the media gets accused of
islamophobia every time that they
criticize her so she uses that as a
shield for her own bigotry
but this is a woman who is on the
foreign affairs committee in the house
she leads a subcommittee under that
committee
she is dealing with real policy issues
that affect allies
like israel while making this insane
moral equivalence between the united
states israel
and u.s government state departments
sanctioned
and and put on lists of terrorist
organizations around the world
terrorist organizations that we have
fought wars over that americans have
died
uh fighting against people who have
attacked us here on our own soil so it
is
far beyond time that not just jewish
democrats in the in the house
condemn her but people like i don't know
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
because
last time this happened two or three
weeks ago there was some condemnation
that nancy pelosi went on the sunday
shows and said really actually i'm not
condemning her so please don't
misconstrue that
but then today you had ilhan omar trying
to kind of walk this back on her twitter
feed
with this gobbly [ __ ] of
intersectionality and justice
and in her original remarks she said
that jewish
colleagues of hers in the house have not
been good partners in justice
well what does that mean to her does
that mean taking away funding for the
iron dome that protects
millions of israeli lives and
palestinian lives and arab lives
in israel is that what that means does a
partner in justice mean
eliminating israel from from the map is
that what she means by that and we have
enough history based on her statements
that that's exactly what she means
you know jesse every side has an extreme
right an extreme person you're one of
bars
extremists yes the difference here is
the media
excuses the left extreme they're very
quick to call out the extremists on the
right but the somehow the left gets to
go
much further until it's no longer
tenable right there's kooks in both
sides yeah
but their kooks are always hating this
country
our kooks don't hate the country they
just have other issues
but she is the naughtiest in her caucus
she's been smacked now by the white
house i believe
pelosi's office banked her in a press
release so she's having a tough year
i'm going to look at her in an
unfavorable light harold and i'm going
to take those
comments she made literally the the
taliban condones atrocities
they condone raping and stoning women
attacks against children attacks against
civilians the united states does not
condone
any of that so she says that she's all
about
she suffered injustice maybe she did she
probably suffered a little
but then as a refugee this country
rescued her brought her here
and we elected her into the congress we
pay for her health care
we pay her salary yet she's violating
all sorts of ethics laws and
immigration laws according to reports so
cnn's trying to rehab her and it blew up
in their face they expected her to say
yes i don't believe that and she just
flat out rejected it so
they have a problem and it's their
problem and
it's fun to watch it certainly is